so Mark Wahlberg would you like to be in
the new Transformers movie what no don't
worry Shia LaBeouf is not in it okay but
listen I'll do it on one condition and
one condition only okay I have to look
at Optimus Prime and go come on optimus
take an interest in science transformers
age of extinction there are four of
these now and this one is once again
directed by Michael Bay however the cast
has severely changed this time Shia
LaBeouf is gone Shia LaBeouf's
girlfriend is gone Shia LaBeouf's other
girlfriend is gone his parents thank
goodness are gone and then replaced with
Mark Wahlberg as an inventor piece that
together that was an inventor joke by
the way as well as the young girl from
The Last Airbender who has been Michael
Bay Fi that's what I call it one you
have a girl who's suddenly in a Michael
Bay movie she has to have like long
blonde hair her makeup has to look
perfect throughout the entire film
always have like these really luscious
pink lips and somehow despite never
actually having access to makeup
throughout the film she always has
incredible makeup but in this movie
humans have decided that transformers
they're not cool anymore the thing that
happened in Chicago we don't like
Autobots or Decepticons none of them
they all have to go so mankind is at war
with these things and now the
transformers are hiding Mark Wahlberg
finds Optimus and they become buddies
and they join this war together well one
of the biggest things that a lot of
people told Michael bate was that his
films especially transformers movies
just had way too much idiotic humor too
much racial stereotypes way too much
government conspiracy dialogue that no
one really cares about and not enough
awesome transformer stuff all the three
previous Transformers films had like the
exact same three act set up you showed
your protagonists they were struggling
with something there's a government
conspiracy going on
Optimus comes in there's a big battle of
sorts or on the second act then more
government conspiracy and stupid idiotic
humor and then by the third act the
entire last 30 to 40 minutes of the
movie is nothing but explosions over and
over again and a lot of people were
thinking well we got a new cast this
time so we're going to get a different
movie it's actually the exact same movie
for the fourth time now I enjoy the
first Transformers movie
I thought that it was a fun film and it
was almost like Michael Bay kinda still
had the reins on him a little bit
because I think some of Bay's earlier
films were actually pretty fun I really
liked the rock I own the blu-ray of the
rock however now all he does is the
exact same movie over and over again
transformers age of extinction is the
exact same film we've had three times
previously it's just with a different
cast and a much more likable lead Mark
Wahlberg the best part of this movie
I'll say that he actually does stuff
like he grabs an alien gun and gets
involved in the battles he doesn't just
run around going bomb blasts over and
over again he actually does stuff in the
film he was a very good asset to the
film his daughter the girl from Last
Airbender despite the fact that I can't
take her seriously because she's been
Michael Bay F eyed it looks like a
Victoria's Secret model and despite
being a young girl the camera lingers
upon her butt and legs throughout the
entire film of course but she did not
give a terrible performance in the movie
her boyfriend however whoa not only was
he terrible in this movie but his
character annoyed the crap out of me he
was a weakling he surrendered to people
all the time he never did anything
really to help these people he was good
at driving the car and besides that Mark
Wahlberg basically owned the entire film
everything else in this movie is just a
two-and-a-half-hour string of explosions
and some of the most idiotic dialogue I
have heard all year my entire goal with
running this channel is to be honest
with you guys about movies I love movies
I love big fun summer entertainment
films I love to watch fun movies I don't
have to just see interesting artsy films
you guys know this my favorite movies
are the big ones that are awesome my
Captain America the Winter Soldier edge
of tomorrow you know these movies are
the kind of movies that we should be
going and shoving popcorn in our face
this film is really dumb no one's ever
said hey Michael Bay he makes movies
with terrible special effects because
that's where you go to these movies for
you want to see transformers rolling
around and kicking each other's asses
and stuff and that's cool it's cool to
see optimus cut through someone with his
sword it's cool to see Optimus riding on
top of
lock all that stuff is fun it's nice to
see some Dinobots I grew up watching
Beast Wars I grew up playing with
transformers I'm a Transformers fan I do
not give a crap about stupid boring
government cheesy dialogue I do not care
about the unfortunately here to stay
Michael Bay humor that is never going to
go away TJ Miller in this movie is awful
he was completely unfunny and such a
stupid character I like TJ Miller
I think TJ Miller is actually really
funny why don't I like him in this movie
because it's Michael Bay a fight he just
runs around in blabber is really
annoying dialogue that's all his
character is therefore guess what this
movie is filled with racial stereotypes
just like all the other Transformers
movies there's even a slavery joke in
this movie Michael Bay does not care
about anything that anyone ever says
about his films in regards to a critical
nature even if it's constructive you
know why because there was thunderous
applause at the end of this film and it
will make a lot of money this is a movie
that is filled with endlessly dumb
scenes poorly constructed dialogue
sequences that just come off as
exposition scenes over and over again in
the first movie they wanted the Allspark
that was the MacGuffin in this movie
it's a seed of some kind and you have
the really stupid annoying comical high
up businessmen who run around with all
their beautiful assistants like in every
single one of them dumb government
scenes in which people get out of cars
in slow motion with the camera
perspective pointed upwards of course
Michael Bay is making the exact same
movies over and over again and I don't
buy it anymore transformers age of
extinction has cool visual effects it
has some fun action sequences but the
majority of them are constructed with
amazing visual effects work done by
extremely talented artists in this film
if there was an action sequence that did
not involve CGI it was rare but there
are a few there's a fight scene or two
it's just a bunch of shaky cam that's
all he just shakes up the camera over
and over again whenever Michael Bay
actually has to get in there and try to
film an action scene with some actual
people it looks terrible the only new
and fresh thing was Mark Wahlberg's
presence but his presence alone
cannot save the fact this movie has no
story nothing in this film feels
cohesive it's a gigantic ly bloated
movie in which every scene feels like
the final battle like every explosion
has fireworks shooting out of it Michael
Bay if you decided to be a director one
day you'd be a great fourth of July
showman I'm gonna give transformers age
of extinction a D+ I did not like this
movie and I'm sick of seeing the same
movie over and over again I think
Michael Bay could make a really good
movie he just doesn't care - he just
wants to make the same stuff over and
over again also I want to let you know
that Michael uu+ promotion is still
going on they have been nice enough to
allow me to give you guys two weeks of
Hulu Plus for free they got in contact
with me and wanted me to offer this deal
with you guys and I said that is awesome
because it's no obligation you can try
out Hulu Plus and see if you like it
there are so many great shows on Hulu
Plus like my favorite drama show the
x-files it has a lot of really great
entertainment movies The Criterion
Collection a large majority of The
Criterion Collection is on Hulu Plus
which is great
for film lovers go to Hulu Plus comm
slash Chris Stockman to get those two
weeks for free thank you so much guys
they're really an awesome company and
they really respect film lovers guys
what is your opinion on this
transformers thing did you think Mark
Wahlberg's presence really added that
much to the film let me know what you
think and as always guys thank you so
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
Munoz
Oh